Ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten.
Yami and a Hikari no match are the fanatic.
This is a fair game, meek.
I'm a fairy caramagawa, a zariake.
A'ly-koi, no kakehi-bukui-i go.
It's not a sign, just a key, I want to hear, a dream, a comfortable, seeing, a way, a way.
Mando was a city.
I'm a, I'ma, a toke-nai, ka-koku teakai, a ko-koku-toku, The darkestrickly and white eyes look at the wall It's like a starlight The angel and the demon The angel and the demon The demon.
Tama-sacac-sac-sac-tanguocu Tengu-cihocu-togu-togu-togu-togu-toguocuocu He-tacu-togu-tehocu-togu-togu If the mama got to dance, Tengoku Tengoku Tengoku Tengoku Monga Akku The night and light The magic Panatic The night The psychedelic The Zodiac The love Love Degg Dead alive Dead Dead Dead Durg Durg Dead Dead Get alive Jet Jet Ah
Oh Oh Oh I'm on a train Oh The black-clue, five-and-a-gallon, The red-haired-wethered-ho-no The sun's red-haired,
The gates of heaven and hell are opening.
The angels, demons, the dead, and the living all, come to dance and laugh together.
Everything is slow, half the chaos The end of the world is here, beginning for all!
Death alive Death alive Death Death Death Birth Birth Death Death Death Death Death Death Death Death
TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE TENGUE
TENGUE Dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance,
dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, dance, do it.